justement sur ces nous ont recensé
toutes les faits que nous risquons
circuler autour de l'incendié d'une
usine de rouen il ya beaucoup de faux
chose qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux qui peuvent faire beaucoup
plient paix et emilie on voulait
absolument que vous soyez avec nous
aujourd'hui merci d'être là on est venu
vous chercher en voiture voilà
aujourd'hui vous avez fait le trajet ça
a été le trajet ou insite saas et ça
s'est bien passé alors je vous le dit
émilie vous vouliez pas là la gare parce
que vous aviez peur voilà deux des
spirées mois en fait maintenant mise à
part pour aller au travail parce que mon
travail est juste à côté enfin à
quelques centaines de mètres on va dire
de lusine mise à part pour le travail je
remets pas les pieds sur euros pour
l'instant après vous sentez vraiment que
vous êtes
il a encore une odeur bien présente deux
de gaz en fait de carburant ça pique le
nez vendredi dernier au travail c'était
des malaises des personnes nauséeuse des
maux de tête et je parle pas des écoles
qui étaient ouvertes et qui ont dû
refermer finalement parce que les
enfants aussi était pris de vomissements
donc c'est dans une situation très très
très compliqué avoue cette mère de deux
enfants de trois et cinq ans oui c'est
ça est-ce qu'ils ont sorti des choses et
de vos enfants
alors pour tout vous dire depuis jeudi
jusqu'à
lundi matin mes enfants étaient en
confinement à la maison n'est pas du
tout sorti jeudi matin mon fils
étonnamment s'est réveillé en faisant
une énorme crise d'asthme mais vraiment
vraiment très très vif avant il en a
fait un petit peu l'année dernière voilà
mais là c'était très violent
donc depuis on a donc il est souvent tôt
line et compagnie je suis retourné voir
le médecin à plusieurs reprises et la
maintenance ou cortisone voilà on
s'inquiète pour nos enfants forcément
bien sûr pour nous pour nous aussi mais
forcément en tant que parent on
s'inquiète vraiment pour le bien-être de
nos enfants
et qu'est ce qu'on vous dit la balle
qu'est ce que vous dites des autorités
avaient levé 10 kapadia pas de danger
les dirigeants qui viennent sur rouen
bon en général ils sont ils sont vite
repartis
elles viennent cinq minutes et puis et
puis on se veut rassurant en fait pour
eux d'après leurs dires l'air ambiant et
comme d'habitude il ya pas de soucis à
ce faire l'air ambiant et comme
d'habitude alors il sur france 2 hier
pompiers qui fait partie des premiers à
avoir approché les dieux qui a raconté
l'ampleur des dégâts regardez ce qu'il
décrit est assez flippant regardez c'est
très rapidement lors du transit
on se rend compte que ça va être une
intervention qui est hors norme un
panache de fumée gigantesque des flammes
de plus de 20 mètres il fait partie des
premiers à pénétrer au plus près du
brasier avec pour seule protection
respiratoire selon lui un masque en
papier mais les moyens manquent
ordre est donné de se replier après une
nuit de lutte le feu est finalement
éteint les pompiers retourne sur les
lieux
quand on voit l'ampleur du sinistre une
fois qu'ils sont éventrés une boussole
qui fait 5 à 10 cm de toutes les
couleurs pendant quelques heures il
souffrira de maux de tête
selon lui plusieurs de ses collègues
seront pris de nausées et de
vomissements alors il paraît que chez
vous il y avait plein d'oiseaux
alors nous on vit à la campagne à
quelques kilomètres de l'usi
on est dans un environnement privilégié
est habituellement ça grouille d'oiseau
on a plein de bestioles c'est la
campagne est en fait pendant trois jours
plus d'oiseaux plus rien c'était comme
une atmosphère d'apocalypse est en fête
et
la petit à petit on voit quelle que soit
vos parties par là mais mais mais c'est
plus comme avant on le ressent bien
l'air ambiant n'est pas pareil les gens
se plaignent énormément de deux de nos
têtes les pharmaciens apparemment de ce
que j'ai pu en discuter avec eux ils
sont débordés il ya beaucoup de
personnes malades alors on met ça sur le
dos des astros des virus du de la saison
mais bon à un moment donné il faut pas
se voiler la face non plus donc
alors il y avait beaucoup aussi le fait
que nous là dessus vous allez voir c'est
news a recensé toutes les faits que nous
on va à venir dans un instant
une vidéo à propos de l' incendie droit
regarder il a publié sur son compte
instagram une vidéo de lui le visage
masqué où il dénonce la situation à un
moment il a dû être mis aux urgences
joey starr froid il a été à l'hôpital sa
part gardé ses vues rapidement vient de
d'annoncer par le biais d'une conférence
de presse que tout se passait bien rouen
ben moi je confirme qu'on était en train
de jouer au théâtre et qui a une odeur
d'essence qui monte dans le théâtre et
que c'est reparti pour un tour
donc c'est super quoi rappeler beaucoup
aussi tchernobyl
tout a été bien quoi voilà donc voilà
big up au genou droit en espérant que on
va survivre à tout ça moi je me casse à
paris retrouvé le bonheur parisien alors
voilà donc c'est vrai que on voit les
gens qui viennent armand sentent quand
même quelque chose sans se sent mal soit
soit des nausées des maux de tête
alors il ya eu plein de fait que nous
aussi et c'est nous ils ont relancé tout
les fennecs n'ont pas ce qu'il faut
faire attention à beaucoup de choses
fausses aussi qu'on voit voilà se
balader sur les réseaux sociaux ou
regarder c'est le lendemain de
l'incendié une vidéo de l'explosion qui
a eu lieu pendant le incendie
c'est faux puisque cette vidéo elle
était filmée en chine en 2015 dans le
même genre vous avez ces photos
d'oiseaux morts sur les routes autour de
rouen là aussi c'est complètement sortie
de son contexte à date de 2011 c'est aux
états unis en louisiane
tout ça ça alimente un petit peu
les inquiétudes encore plus des
riverains et puis vous avez art là c'est
beaucoup plus grave
info communiquez avec le logo de la
préfecture et le logo de l' agence
régionale de santé ars qui dit que des
effets dangereux pour la santé
la préfecture a démenti envisage de
porter plainte puisqu'il ya usage de
faux sûr que quand même un logo de
l'état alors il ya au moins 1800
agriculteurs qui ont été touchées par
les incendies de lusine lubrizol
je pense beaucoup aux agriculteurs parce
que déjà qu'ils ont une option du mal
ils ont beaucoup de mal les peaux voilà
on pense très fort à eux on espère que
ils vont pouvoir s'en sortir avec ça
aussi voilà et puis il ya le préfet lui
le préfet de normandie qui prétend ne
rien cacher donc c'est pierre andré
durand
il a réagi à la polémique sur
d'éventuels choses qui seraient cachés
il ne voit pas pourquoi cela serait le
cas c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'il a dit
donc le préfet vous aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que vous avez du mal à vivre sur
rouen mais lui dit que tout va bien
wen sur les alentours bah ouais c'est ça
brouille pas s'étaler jusqu'à 26
kilomètres on a des retombées de suite
c'est plus du double du carburant
de l'hydrocarbure c'est pas les produits
chimiques oui pardon mais moi je me mêle
de ce qui me ramène dans ses produits
chimiques s'arrêtera il posera ne rien
avoir une rien ne se passe et
s'efforçait depuis ses obligés de on est
obligé de cacher les choses
regardons c'est l'affolement général ou
enfin s'est passé regardez ce qu'ils
nous vivons c'est ainsi dans un climat
de suspicion généralisée les propos des
pouvoirs publics sont souvent mis en
doute parfois même ne sont pas cru nous
nous attachons à produire des analyses à
les mettre en ligne
à permettre à tout un chacun de s'y
intéresser les images qu'on a pu voir
notamment sont elles sont assez
alarmante
je vous lis pourtant le préfet devant
lui donc il a dû il a dit les hyper
rassurant trouvé que la qualité de l'air
était normal vous trouvez que la qualité
de l'air vous avec des gens qui
vomissent ou non pas du tout là encore
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui çà çà çà
çà çà tu es ça ça sentait
d'hydrocarbures à plein nez il ya encore
des écoles qui ont dû fermer
précipitamment aujourd'hui parce que les
enfants se sentait très mal je pense que
même je pense que même les maires de
chaque commune se sentent un petit peu
délaissé parce que ils font un peu comme
bon leur semble en fait ici face à une
situation inconnue pour eux il ya ma
d'arrêter ya rien on est là c'est pas
les odeurs en plus c'est pas que les
odeurs encore l'odeur ça passerait mais
c'est ce qu'il ya dans l'air les
particules chimiques on sait pas ce que
c'est exactement la liste définitive en
fait la liste définitive des produits
qui ont été et n'est pas connu et donc à
certains députés qui disent maintenant
il faudrait qu'ils demandent maintenant
aux préfets notamment qu'il y ait la
liste de ces produits là parce qu'on ne
les connais pas on donne deux trois
n'ont donc que me donne pas la liste
définitive donc certains députés alors
comme ça joli il ya beaucoup si de fait
nous pour l'instant je vous le dise
qu'on nous dise qu'on ne lui a pas de
cas voilà deux personnes gravement
atteintes
gravement malade voilà donc je vous dis
donc voilà on espère voilà que ce qu'ils
disent est vrai et qu'il n'y a pas de
grand danger pour les habitants devront
et de la région beaucoup de monde vous
dit est très préoccupé par la situation
non on en pense on y pense tous les
jours voilà n'ont pas tous les jours au
bureau les images qu'on a pu voir c'est
vrai qu'elles sont assez alarmante et
donc le préfet de rouen lui il est
toujours hyper rassurant on espère que
ce qu'il dit est vrai voilà on est
certes tous ici il a dit la qualité de
l'air est normal du coup ça nous
arrivait d'un eu l'idée d'un petit
montage regardent et goûtent et moi je
vis à rouen je travaille à rouen et donc
il n'y a pas de risque pour la santé
je ne peux pas dire qu'il n'ya pas de
danger il ya forcément des traces
d'hydrocarbures de produire sur les
composés organiques volatils sont tous
inférieurs au seuil de quantification la
ville est clairement polluée
la qualité de l'air est habituel
peut-être la messe sera taxée arrivée à
la gare routière c'est là qu'on a vu des
as et s'appliquant il ya eu sur l'eau
potable
aucun problème donc une nature c'est pas
envie dtt d'avoir quelque chose pour la
santé c'est vrai que c'est pas terrible
donc je vous confirme qu'il est possible
de vivre un roman aujourd'hui tout à
fait normalement parce que jean michel
perin informel juste avant de partir
j'ai vu aux infos y avait une nouvelle
conférence de presse du préfet et des
autorités de santé de la région qui
disait que la liste définitive des
produits qui étaient dans les usines
vont maintenant être en ligne maintenant
il pourra le faire avance que pour des
questions d'attentats on peut pas mettre
les listes des produits en ligne jackson
viennent d'éventuels cible pour les
terroristes
donc maintenant cessé en ligne et ils
reconnaissent qu'il ya quand même des
produits dangereux qui ont été
éparpillés dans le ciel qui tombe
éventuellement dans les jardins etc
les enfants peuvent toucher ne pas y
toucher qui aura des équipes
spécialisées qui vont venir dans les
jardins dans les maisons le préfet avait
avait lancé un autre communiqué nous
disant justement de nettoyer par nous
mêmes
tous les tous les matins avec des
lingettes surtout pas surtout pas de
karcher sur les terrasses par exemple la
terrasse de mes parents bâle est noire
de suie très grasses et en fait on a
beau même nettoyé même avec des
protections ça ne part pas parce que ça
colle donc les enfants par la force des
choses même dans les cours de récréation
même si c'est nettoyé sur sur les
toboggans aux caisses et nettoyer mais
mais ça reste collant est les particules
sont là g
alors on va on va suivre bien sûr à
cette affaire ici aussi emilie vous nous
donner des nouvelles
voilà donc fait attention et je vous dis
comme à dijon michel il faut pas toucher
aux particules voilà qui sont dans votre
jardin essayé voilà deux voilà d'appeler
vous enterrez compte que si tout le
monde appelait les appelle les autorités
vont être débordées travail va être mis
en place des modes c'est un travail
colossal merci et pas moi